hi this is um a film that may be of only
interested in me because I've never
searched or asked anybody if they feel
the same as me
it's also taken me a long many many
years to feel brave enough to
talk about it
you might think oh well you you're old
you're
you're a big strong guy what do you mean
then talk about it the things are
personal to us we sometimes don't really
want to share in case we we feel
affordable
um just won't keep our private thoughts
to ourselves
but this is a subject that's
wow I can't remember how many years back
I questioned it
and I'm going to share it with you just
in case you you're like me and you may
have had the same thoughts and
experiences
now I've been teaching for
about
47 years
46 47 years
and I didn't think about this until I
was in my later downgrade years
possibly third and fourth down perhaps
even going into my fifth but let but
let's just say around about third or
fourth down
I started thinking about it
this may not be of any interest to you
as if you're not a teacher
but as a student You may wish to think
about it and if you ever become a
teacher or you notice you're doing it
just by helping another person on the
mat you could even make you great help
telling another person same level or
lower
some people have a cheeky enough
to be a lot lower grade than the person
they're trained with and still trying to
tell the senior
what to do
this happens quite a lot it's very rude
and um
something that shouldn't really be
encouraged
but
this is normally
if they may not agree this is normally
driven by the person's ego they don't
see it as ego they just say as telling
the person because it feels wrong the
person may be struggling with them
on how they feel that they should do it
better and yeah being a lower grade more
than money can't do it yourself correct
but their ego will think they can
so
I don't really know the answer even
though I'm going to give you my answer
but I still question it even today after
all these years
of what I think the answer is
to this film
when we train
we I've got here two caps
my old
pretty worn out
cap that I managed to King Canada that
I'm very proud of most go on the Rocky
Mountain train
um
very costly but something that we wanted
to do later in life and this cap I was
given this this young cat I was given
and what I like it is because it's got
this nice brass the clip on the back
and to me anything with a brass clip on
the back
rather than a velcro strap
is a better cap
you have no idea what this costs this
cap
but you know it's red it's bright it's
young looking
the old black cap the
I walk the dog with and
go out with because you know it's
comfortable it feels good
I don't really know I've got it on
but this cat
well now I feel younger
president Trump
wears red caps and he's in his 70s isn't
he
is it because he feels younger vibrant
lots of energy
I've no idea and I'm no idea what you
might think of him and that's not
important in this case
it takes me back to thinking about my
mother when she was 80 and I was 50.
mum I said what do you think
the difference is between 50 and 80.
I'll put this on because she said
in my head I still think I'm 20.
but I get a lot more tired nowadays
so
does this cap
suit me
now the age I am
so this brings me on to this story of
student and teacher
and and the Aikido that we do
as a teacher
as a student
so I'm changing caps
but I sit here or with my age unchanged
[Music]
so it doesn't matter what age you are
when you're training on the mat
but as the student
this cat is worn
or it has been by me
whether it makes sense to you this film
or be down to the individual
and whether you say it through to the
end
now this curve
I feel great I feel young
makes me so that people might think I'm
old looking at me but I'm not old my
head's still thinking that perhaps I'm
not 20 but you know it's still thinking
of when I was younger
so when I try to train on the mat
why do I make so many mistakes why do I
keep thinking you know as much as I
might be enjoying it
I'm still working on a lot of things and
knowing that I'm getting it wrong a lot
I might even be having a lot of fun and
I may be even better than the person I'm
training with
but I still go home thinking you know I
struggled a bit with that one oh I had
such a good night but yeah I must work
on my footwork or
so so
while enjoying our training we
constantly have the head of a student
on and we we make lots of mistakes while
doing good work as well
so the ego is how it's had a lot of fun
and and
I might
sort of think
that was such a busy class tonight
I found all our time to was breathe
I might have had the odd conversation
with my partner but on a busy night I I
used my time for getting my breath back
rather than having a chat about things
or discussing things
then I perhaps go on a seminar with this
young spirited person full of energy
can't wait to get on the seminar
and um
I'm training with different people
and I might feel quite good oh my God
it's pretty good compared to a lot of
the people here my style must be better
than theirs because I've got really good
Aikido
or you might be otherwise think oh dude
I can't do anything with these people
you know I'm really struggling
everything's wrong I can't move them I
don't know what part to look at first or
what part to look at to improve
so
so we've got like yin and yang going on
even as the student even as the young
person
I don't matter what your age is
we've got the students head on
where we're either
patting ourselves saying how good we
feel against other styles other people
we've never met
always saying how much in our mind we're
struggling and
what am I going to do what's where
should I work on first so that I improve
then we get the people and I've done it
as well
I remember saying to somebody higher
than me and looking back I shouldn't
have said it but at the time
if I did I just came out
somebody was trying to do kosher Nag on
me and couldn't do it I believe I've
said this in a film before
so I started telling them where they
need to position there just a second
to change hats
ah this is the good old hat
this is a hat
look that gives me confidence because it
doesn't make me feel out of place it
doesn't make me feel
as if that red white one
I'm not a Brash person
I know what I'm talking about I'm sound
I'm firm you know